get off my plane
[Music]
air force one so air force one came out
in 1997 directed by wolfgang pedersen
and the premise is harrison ford placed
the president the president's plane air
force one has been hijacked by
terrorists
so now harrison ford is the lone soldier
they don't know about
on that plane is going to stop him
that's right
the president is the john mcclane of
this story and that's just kind of
awesome what a
flip you know you know the initial idea
for this movie was oh air force one's
been hijacked
so someone has to save air force one and
then
someone was like what if the president
is that soldier i mean how could you say
no at that point that's just amazing
it's
90 is amazing yes also more amazing than
2020 amazing
so there's that the music's amazing too
that jerry goldsmith's score
but it just sounds heroic it just sounds
like
the kind of music that someone could
play in their campaign trail
and get elected
obviously it's like the music sounds
like it was taken from the dna
of america itself
like the only thing the only music that
would have made this movie better in
terms of music
[Music]
but great music though and generally the
movie's really engaging because of
harrison ford
and gary oldman who plays the bad guy
neither of them need any introduction at
this point but
for harrison ford lately we've seen him
get pulled back into movies and
franchises he's not
really passionate about but when this
dude brings it
he brings it second to [ __ ] none man
it's harrison ford and this was back
when that was harrison four and harrison
ford does a great job in this movie i
mean from the get-go he's like he just
completely
upends the foreign policy and he's just
like harris your days are numbered and
at worst
people are like dude you should have run
that bias before you went off scripts
but generally they're all like
but we're behind you we got it you're
you and among all the semi-important
lessons the 90s had to teach us one of
my big takeaways from that decade
is that gary oldman is one of the
greatest actors living
and always a perfect casting for a bad
guy when he's calm
he's scary when he's screaming he's
scary
when he's screaming and he fires a gun
at the wall and then screams again
he's scary dude is always scary and
right when he's like i'm going to
execute a hostage
every half hour until my demands are met
his demands being he wants this
war criminal [ __ ] he just wants him
released because he was just recently
captured in russia and he makes good on
that that's not a lot of time so you
feel the time crunch
also glenn close plays the vice
president she's very important because
this movie runs into what
executive decision also runs into for me
which is you have a hostage situation
in a plane it's in the sky right you
have the good guys
or good guy in this case they're in the
belly of the plane
they gotta wait to make their move
now we wait not that the movie doesn't
have pacing not that it's not
going forward but really it's not
harrison ford
versus gary oldman the whole time the
main source of tension is gary oldman
talking to washington dc
everyone in the war room and they're
trying to be like hey we need more time
then harrison ford when he contacts them
but that's the point it's it's a lot of
talking tension
more talking tension than you would
think if you go into this movie thinking
oh it's a 90s action movie which the
movie seems very aware of because in the
last act it starts throwing
plane explosions and more action-esque
sequences in this movie than you had had
before
other than some rando going down running
across harrison ford and getting taken
out but another thing i always found
interesting in this movie about glenn
close's storyline you know the war room
dynamics
it starts getting brought up as to
whether or not the president in this
situation
can still be the president you look at
harrison ford really he's on this plane
he didn't
go into the escape pod and escape
because his family is still on air force
one so as i said in this movie he's not
acting as the president he's acting as a
husband and a father it's this side arc
in air force one but it's an element of
this movie that i just
always remember one of the things that
always has me scratching my head is
there's this
guy who's part of the secret service but
he's a bad
guy and that's no spoiler you see this
from the get-go if it was a reveal that
would have been kind of cool
there's there's no reveal there he's
just obviously the bad guy
and they let you know that early on the
whole time though i'm like what was
what was he offered what what did they
promise him what does he
benefit by having this guy released you
kind of get the feeling everyone likes
and respects harrison ford's character
so this dude just totally
goes turn coat what why though
is he brody from homeland did something
happen that just leaves you scratching
your head as to why that happened but it
happened because
i suppose if it didn't happen no one
could have gotten on air force one
because in the end air force one's
always an enjoyable watch it's not as
iconic
to me it's like face off conair the rock
any of that but every time i watch it i
thoroughly enjoy it harrison ford was
great as was gary oldman you feel the
tension in the movie
doesn't move as much as some of the
other 90s action movies but the tension
is there
and the fact that the president is the
last best hero to save the president
it's just too good he's the man's man
the president's president and this movie
is a good time no alcohol required
all right so air force one it's on
netflix right now have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you